il ne revendique régulièrement qu'il y
allait maps et n'est pas né avec une
cuillère en or dans la bouche nez dans
le 19e arrondissement de paris c'est à
bondy qu'il passera une partie de son
enfance des quartiers populaires qui lui
ont beaucoup apporté dans le players
tribune le prodige de 21 ans s'est
exprimé à ce sujet les gens dehors de
france par le toujours des banlieues de
façon négative mais quand vous n'êtes
pas de là bas vous ne pouvez pas
comprendre ce que c'est avant de
déconstruire les clichés tenaces la
réalité que quand j'étais petit j'avais
l'habitude de voir certains des gars les
plus dures de mon quartier porter les
courses de ma grand mère vous ne voyez
jamais ce côté là de notre culture aux
infos vous entendez toujours parler du
mauvais jamais dumont un article où il
se raconte et parle de son parcours
un parcours qu'il souhaite ériger en
exemple pour les plus jeunes il faut
dire qu'à seulement 21 ans qui viennent
elle bat p a de quoi donner l'exemple si
son père entraîneur de football lui mais
très vite un ballon entre les pieds à 11
ans seulement le jeune fils yann se
retrouve avec son équipe l'as bondy en
demi finale de la coupe de
seine-saint-denis en 2011 il rejoint
l'institut national du football de
clairefontaine avant de recevoir la
proposition de clubs prestigieux parmi
eux la hesse monaco dont l'équipe
première fait cette année là son retour
en ligue 1 un club où il progressera aux
côtés des plus grands à 17 ans il
deviendra le plus jeune joueur à porter
le maillot de cette équipe mais aussi le
plus jeune buteur de l'histoire du club
deux ans plus tard m vapeur emporte la
ligue 1 avec monaco face au psg un club
qui l'intégrera l'année suivante pour un
contrat faramineux bref au cours de sa
carrière m bape et aura battu beaucoup
de record de précocité et montre que
malgré son jeune âge sa capacité à jouer
de grands matches et sans faille
un parcours exemplaire que le jeune
homme veut transmettre comme une
expérience à reproduire
l'apéro c'est quoi cette lettre l'ady
gil
c'est une initiative géniale il est très
jeune il parle à ces jeunes des
territoires de banlieue comme un homme
politique savez moi je travaillais
méritoire de bonlieu l'autre camp je
travaille à aucun quand je travaillais
au parisien on disait il faut pas
stigmatiser les villes de banlieue parce
que des gens y vivent est il sain sur
eux et lui fait ça à lui tout seul je
trouve qu'il arrive à rendre belle la
banlieue et ses villes qui sont parfois
des dragons les échanges de ces
reportages ou à chaque fois on nous
parle de la banlieue on voit on a
l'impression que c'est l'enfermement
joris mathieu zone en banlieue et il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de talent qui sortent
des banlieues et mine de rien de plus en
plus de ce que je vois que ce soit dans
le milieu de la télévision dans le
milieu minerai démarre fort du cinéma il
ya beaucoup beaucoup de talent qui
sortent de plus en plus de la banlieue